hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to destroy the porn I have
no idea what porn is sir why we need to
destroy it but hey I'm a log to go with
the game a you know fun why would we do
this
welcome to hell Joe um come again you
have died and gone to hell why hey
Wiggins subkey BAPS [ __ ] this is
terrible you don't say that things have
gotten much better down here we even
have a PF Changs now no no no it's not
that
why are we my poor mother goes through
my stuff she's gonna fight a metric ton
of porn yes there some way you can send
me back to earth well technically yes
but it's very dangerous I'll do it
whatever the cost I don't think you
understand
no we're talking about there I can't be
that bad oh really
[Music]
oh okay
diaper porn cross I can't it huh you are
a super a key person
alright look if you can survive hell's
labyrinth and defeat the base at the end
you then have one minute back on earth
to do whatever you so desired one minute
is all I need huh how soon can I start
right now yay now I don't know what any
of those words meant did he say triple
fisting I think he might have said that
I have no idea how hard could this be
she's it anyway so anyway I played uh
spike traps huh ah that's all you got
anyway I played it just to see if it was
working it was crashing a little bit but
I hope that I got it stable enough to
the what gotta find a way back up there
what can't I jump that's what I couldn't
figure out I can oh alright bouncy
trousers okay now jump
okay there we go I got it by pressing K
why would I press K - oh because I can
use WASD okay so now that I have the
impeccable ability to jump I'm still
gonna go off and destroy this a
mysterious horn type device it must be a
diabolical thing that nobody should ever
encounter in their life probably just
the worst of the worst type of thing
just go back to hell and stop by the PF
- hello excuse me pardon me pardon me
scuse me pardon me speed running this
[ __ ] what the hell were those things I
think he said wait I am speedrunning
this [ __ ] let me go okay can't go that
way
Shope adobo dope show but whoa hello you
no no no no with your freakish now oh no
no not today
Oh oh my god do Mulligan sorry oh you're
not well not one hit kill
I got enough free oh no no no this
supposed to be a very hard game but I
don't know what they're tired about
being hard they gave me a friggin oh my
god okay never mind that oh I see how
this is
no no no no no no stay away I'm just
gonna run past you why do I even need to
bother I ran past you the first time
why do I need to kill you now I am the
man I am the ultimate man up scuse me
find me tell me to buy on you oh okay I
got it I got it
I get it I get it nah same so bad it
ain't so bad
something sit over here we go sobbing
such a baby man I know you're on the
quest to whatever the hell you're trying
to do but whoa hello no no oh God
okay okay no I see what I need to do
jump booster press Kane here will now
give me a small boost yeah oh this is a
lot of fun oh hello I can go up this way
yes
oh I'm doing so good at this game I
honestly thought that this is gonna be a
rage type game but I'm actually doing
fantastically okay I spoke too soon is
where things go horribly wrong is where
everything falls the asses around me and
all of my dreams go crumbling down or I
just keep going speed running I'm just
gonna do just fine something you
everybody so much for watching
yep there you up dope dope now there was
a way that it said that I could load the
game but I don't know how to save the
game in the first place okay can't go
that way maybe I'm gonna get a powerup
to go through the fire huh yeah try to
give me I wanna shoot the hell out of
you that's right Oh Oh death pain 'i'm
armor not even hot lava can stop me now
why do I even want to leave hell I mean
honestly I'm worried for my poor mother
seeing what whatever porn is oh that's
what happened this morning
oh why is it gonna crash
[ __ ] come on
oh you're gonna be a death of me you son
of a [ __ ] ass [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
piece of hump or dick I don't even know
what porn is but [ __ ] you and I hope you
enjoy it
yay
okay so I think I fix it I'm not sure I
had to edit some things I had to go
through some pain but here I am and it
doesn't look like have the armor anymore
but I actually doing it's not gonna
crash right he's dead
okay so there's some way to do this look
the bug the bones okay okay okay I get
it I get I'm supposed to do I was
supposed to go the other way
so they wouldn't have to go down there
anymore now I'm gonna go the right
direction
okay this is just fine
god damn it I went through that so many
times
okay but I though boy ain't gonna kill
me I love grants there ever was
no get out of here with your stupidness
I'm going up this way I don't even know
what's up with okay come on there we go
alright so I'm back into the swing of
things back into speedrun mode back into
not dying like a douche mode oh oh okay
now I can boost an air for all eternity
good for me I can I'm so happy you don't
even understand how happy I could've
just gone this way okay
what is this even for I don't know how
Oh
least give me a checkpoint that was nice
of you can't believe how nice your
journey I don't get it why are you
trying to stop people from going back to
earth tell you how easy it is for me the
Beast video you got it he's dead
gotta go up wait a minute here okay no
no I'm just gonna stay down here okay
okay all right then okay that's right Oh
Oh how's that feel buh-bye you'll pay
for that
you're got a lamp but I'll slap
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah little [ __ ]
I'm gonna kick your ass
yeah oh oh no oh no
well that must hurt Oh Oh another one
huh
no not today you down son you done you
did yeah hey today
where's no I hate you my last breath to
my home in Santa Ana
Zella by hell with someone what go there
what there's a California joke maybe I
don't know
oh hi oh this guy so let's do this born
I didn't come in Florida to do this
that's not a euphemism but you know what
I mean oh boy oh god how much more did I
have who did the mom not notice
seriously oh god I'm not gonna make it
hi guys just hold down the button what
do they know about that I got this hold
down the thing it's such a friggin idiot
yeah yeah I know I get it yeah yeah yeah
yeah lots of porn lots of porn it's so
much fun just endless streams of porn
like a bait you will be mad baby I don't
know maybe they have porn in hell
whatever
we're just not used to I did it oh oh
yeah I did it I did it I destroyed all
the porn I did it congratulations Joe
you have conquered Hell's labyrinths and
destroyed the Beast Within how do you
feel I feel like the [ __ ] man good
what next for Joe the destructor did you
say something about a PF Changs yes Joe
yes I did hahaha
freeze frame on jump ok thank you for
playing thank you everybody so much for
watching if you wanna play this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]